ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
dans un instant sur notre antenne en
direct vous allez pouvoir suivre la
suite du projet de loi de développement
économique pour l'outre-mer ce matin les
sénateurs ont entériné le principe de la
création d'un fonds exceptionnel
d'investissement pour l'outre-mer la
discussion reprend à l'article 20 sur la
réforme de la défiscalisation en matière
de logement social dans les dom bonne
séance à tous
alors nous reprenons la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi pour le
développement économique de l'outre-mer
dans la discussion des articles nous en
sommes parvenus à l'article 20 et je
suis saisi d'un nombre important de
d'intervention sur article alors gélita
hoarau n'est pas là serge larcher qui
commence
vous avez la parole monsieur le sénateur
président monsieur b ni celui des objets
chers collègues le relais poids moins
d'un défiscalisation vers le social
opéré par le texte n'est rien moins que
véritable piège pour l'outre-mer
c'est un pari pour logement social si
improbable qu'il ait réservé à nouveau
maire il existe en métropole aucun
système de défiscalisation du logement
social qui devait financer exclusivement
sur les crédits budgétaires
le dispositif le plus social elle le
borloo populaire qui est en fait destiné
au secteur intermédiaire la réforme
gilou vise simplement à pallier
tiquement une pénurie budgétaire était
entérinée par le pool outre-mer par les
pouvoirs publics la réforme pour vous
aimeriez - un habillage élégant du
désintérêt de l'état de maisons sociales
elle doit un droit fondamental
nulle part sur le territoire national il
est sorti de la compétence de l'état il
est sorti la prod litres excepté
notre merde c'est indigne vouloir
déployer la défiscalisation vers le
logement social
olemps choix du pari hasardeux soit la
volonté inavouée de tuer cette situation
entre mr défiscaliser le mouvement
social en lieu et place d'une france
libre ont été remis hier diminuer très
fortement l'intérêt de l'investissement
pour les investisseurs métropolitains
qui dit logement social du plafonnement
des loyers des loyers de beste revenus
locatifs réalité l'orientation vers
mental pour le premier 1 et nullement
d'accroître un vrai fiscaux liés à
l'investissement locatif social
c'est même tout le contraire sous la
base de simulations la fédération des
scènes d'outre-mer l'hypothèse d'une
rentabilité négative de l'investissement
l'enquêté sociale que mr est de loin la
plus probable propice à décourager des
investisseurs a fortiori dans ce
contexte fort remontée des taux
d'intérêt notamment le secteur
immobilier
l'objectif annoncé par cette mesure est
de relancer la politique de logement
dans les dom or qu'en est il réellement
le projet de loi jégo supprimons croiser
tout la croisille totalité la
défiscalisation des joueurs libres ou
intermédiaires dont les cadres actuels
déçu de la loi girardin y réserver le
bénéfice de cette dépense fiscale aux
seuls programmes immobiliers comprenant
un certain pourcentage de logements
sociaux donné en location sous une
double condition de plafond concernant
d'une part les loyers et d'autre part
les ressources des locataires
ce recentrage de la destination autre
maire répond et a été un objectif dans
les chemins des contraintes financières
pour l'état
il ressort des travaux préparatoires du
projet de loi jégo que le vrai reproche
fait à des figurations delajoux nombreux
maires et son coût jugé positif ou les
finances publiques des critiques
adressées à la distillation de le joueur
de première sont exactement les mêmes
que celles qui y ont été faites au
dispositif de secours les terres ou bien
par métropole mais en métropole le
dispositif robien n'a été modifié
et qu'à la marche et non supprimée dans
ce soit autre forme de procès com se
propose de faire pour l'outre-mer le
texte de la lodeom l'affirmation selon
laquelle la défiscalisation est
détournée dans les dom des opérateurs du
btp des appels d'offres proposées par
les maîtres d'ouvragé sociaux occulte la
véritable raison de cinq sites cette
situation qui découle largement des
délais de règlement excessif de la
filière de logement social a raison la
dette accumulée par l'état de son
incapacité à produire ses propres
engagements vis-à-vis des bailleurs les
dispositions relatives à la
défiscalisation le lien social sont
inadaptées car des phillies écart
défiscaliser ou non les investissements
locatifs privilégie toujours ou première
comment être comme en métropole des
petites surfaces car celles ci peuvent à
la fois être loués très hachée au mètre
carré au vent du placement et ne
répondent en rien aux contraintes
économiques et opérationnelles des
projets nous savons tous que que c'est
la halle berry qui finance le logement
social outre-mer
elle doit d'ailleurs est-il sort comme
l'a dit ce matin elle est affirmé ce
matin du financement du logement social
et le dispositif de défiscalisation pour
poser dans le projet de loi doit
permettre une production complémentaire
de logements sociaux et intermédiaires
et en aucun cas se substituer à la
ressource budgétaire
en effet deux dispositifs de
défiscalisation est une souche aléatoire
par nature car elle dépend la dynamique
des investisseurs personne morale ou
physique
or dans le contexte actuel de crise
sociale dans les départements
d'outre-mer et que suffisante
financières en général
personne ne peut être assurées de la
mobilisation des ressources à court
terme
le principe de mixité du financement de
la lb eu et défiscalisation demande donc
à être clarifiées afin de permettre une
instruction destruction efficace des
dossiers
soulignons aussi que l'impact médiatique
des événements qui ont touché la
guadeloupe et la martinique est
aujourd'hui la guyane hier la guyane est
aujourd'hui la réunion se traduira par
un fort flux
des projets d'investissement la
possibilité de cumuler lb eu et
défiscalisation doit être également
clarifié je remercie
merci serge larcher
la parole est un genre patient sur le
président les barrages de novembre 2008
opéré en guyane les événements qui
secoue qui ont secoué la guadeloupe à ce
que depuis plus de plusieurs semaines et
la martinique
maintenant la réunion trouvent leur
fondement même si le mal s avère plus
profond dans les mêmes problématiques à
savoir la vie chère dans un tel contexte
la question du logement devient central
dans la mesure où le budget qui est
consacré au couple souvent plus de 30%
des dépenses des ménages
le loyer les charges ont connu ces
dernières années des hausses pied
supérieur au coût de la vie pourtant dit
c'est d'ailleurs la raison qui a poussé
le gouvernement à modifier les
caractéristiques de l' indice des loyers
avec l'instauration d'un indice de
référence des loyers base et non plus
uniquement sur le coût de la
construction mais plus largement sur les
indices des coûts à la consommation nous
constatons par ailleurs en guyane que
ces augmentations ont atteint des taux
records avec un marché du logement
notamment dans la ville capitale
complètement orientée à la hausse dans
un contexte de pénurie de logements on a
même dans certains cas analysé un marché
de la demande
à la place du marché de l'offre le
logement offert aux plus offrants
ceci s'est accompagnée par une flambée
des prix des coûts de la construction et
de production
nous voyons bien aujourd'hui que l'on
atteint le point de non retour et que la
question du logement et des loyers reste
problématique et sans solution tangible
à court terme
de plus sans entrer dans la polémique
des chiffres récents publiés par l'insee
les moins de 25 ans représentent plus de
60% de la population totale
une force pour certains mais aussi une
bombe à retardement puisque gérer
l'éducation l'insertion professionnelle
accès à un logement et à l'emploi pour
un très grand nombre ne sera pas chose
aisée dans un tel contexte économique la
question du logement sera donc très
prochainement encore plus préoccupante
des solutions nouvelles sont à inventer
rapidement l'accession à la propriété
est sans doute la première d'entre elles
est plus spécifiquement l'accession
sociale reste une réponse au logement du
plus grand normand guyane mais elle se
heurte depuis plusieurs années à un
archaïsme ou à la disparition de ces
mécanismes de financement je parlais du
des prés du crédit foncier de france
délivrée autrefois notamment au près
comme à nanterre l as et à une lente
dégradation du volume de terrains
équipés à coût modéré
la sueur bancarisation du système actuel
a sans doute trouvé ses limites
sans entrer dans la polémique accéder à
tout prix peut devenir un leurre si
l'endettement est trop important alors
qu'au contraire nous avons une majorité
de ménages ne manqua reese en guyane qui
aspire à la propriété plus par pure
tradition au mode de vie que par choix
économiques
c'est une force il est nécessaire de
s'en servir
le recours non pas systématique au
crédit mais l'instauration d'une plus
grande souplesse dans le mécanisme de
financement du ls par exemple doit
permettre la construction de logements
de masse évolutif tout en respectant
l'environnement notion de logement
durable des moyens financiers également
adéquats seront nécessaires puisque
aujourd'hui les subventions ne
représente guère qu'à peine 30 % du coût
total hors achat du terrain et viable et
viabilisation alors que dans les années
90 elle atteignait la moitié du coût
deux champs d'investigation se doivent
d'être étudié
soit revoir la politique des prix ou
bien d'excès les subventions sur les
véritables coûts de la construction
l'étroitesse du marché guyanais le quasi
monopole de certains groupes ne facilite
sans doute pas les choses en la matière
la quasi hégémonie du choix du logement
locatif social a entraîné celui ci dans
une impasse le nombre de demandeurs de
logements sociaux locatifs est à ce jour
bien supérieures à l'ensemble du parc de
logements existant construit la courbe
de la demande croît de manière
exponentielle alors que la production
stagne et que le phénomène ne cesse de
segré d'année de se dégrader pardon au
vu de la croissance démographique la
politique des loyers opéré en
systématisant le loyer plafond ne rend
plus le logement locatif attractif grand
ménage modeste
cette politique est pourtant la seule
alternative pour les bailleurs sociaux
puisqu'ils doivent également prendre en
compte le financement de l'aménagement
des terrains les équipements publics et
bien souvent l'assainissement collectif
pour toutes ces raisons nous atteignons
ses prix de loyer certes autorisé par la
loi mais trop élevé pour la majorité des
bénéficiaires des choix nouveaux en la
matière sont possibles notamment par
l'intermédiaire de création de zac
comme c'est le cas à saint laurent du
maroni ou un mac orient il est urgent
d'en programmer d'autres qui dès
maintenant et le métro nous en la
matière serait diversification pour
permettre le financement d'opérations
croisé public-privé social et
intermédiaire avec les équipes en
parallèle quels dispositifs pour
répondre à cette problématique
l'exploration d'un véritable plan du
logement en guyane à l'instar de ce qui
vient d'être lancé à la réunion le
développement d'opérateurs sociaux
intermédiaires et associatives soutenu
par les pouvoirs publics afin d'impulser
nouvelle dimension viseront à
l'augmentation de l'offre de logements
se diriger vers une grande
diversification des produits logement à
croître
l'offre de logements locatifs à loyers
maîtrisés dans le parc public mais aussi
dans le parc privé l'ancienne politique
d'accession à la propriété notamment
social et intermédiaire et le
développement de l'offre de solutions
d'hébergement ou de logement spécifique
pour les populations marginalisées ou en
insertion
cela demande bien entendu des moyens
humains et financiers conséquents mais
avant tout surtout une volonté politique
sans faille de faire de la question du
logement plus qu'une priorité locale un
devoir vis-à-vis de la jeunesse
merci bien georges patient la parole est
à richard tuheiava le président je me
réserve les amendements merci gens
tiennent antoinette avait la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre collègues
permettez moi de faire une remarque de
fonds avant l'examen de cet article la
question du logement social en outre mer
est trop grave trop tragique même
pourquoi on achemine aussi vers le
marché de la spéculation
ce qui constitue avant tout un droit
fondamental de la personne humaine droit
que vous avez même rendue opposable à ce
droit touche à des problématiques
sociales lourdes ainsi qu'à des
problématiques de santé particulièrement
tenace en outre-mer ou l'insuffisance de
logements décents produit son corollaire
dans la prolifération de l'habitat
spontané et insalubres
ce droit fondamental c'est d'abord une
politique publique volontariste de la
garantir sans compter sur le bon vouloir
des investisseurs qu'il va falloir
appâter ce qui con con quoi qu'on fasse
produit des effets d'aubaine et des
effets pervers
la loi girardin a justement produit ses
effets pervers d'augmentation de la
spéculation financière
mais tout de même ce mât ce marché du
logement libre et intermédiaires avaient
trouvé preneur il y avait de la demande
des entreprises du btp en prospérer des
emplois ont été créés et des familles
ont accédé à des produits qui
correspondait
à leur évolution sociale économique en
outre-mer 80% de la population relève du
logement social
c'est donc que 20% ou presque en
dépassent les plafonds
ce qui n'est pas négligeable par
ailleurs au sein même de la population
relevant du logement social la mobilité
professionnelle et économique existe un
tant soit peu et aboutit donc aux
aspirations de nombreux foyers à
parcours résidentiel ascendant du
collectif à l'individuel du locatif à
l'accession du social à l'intermédiaire
pensez vous qu'on recentrons un
dispositif conçu pour le logement livre
vers le logement social
vous répondrez véritablement aux
attentes des populations d'outre-mer les
plus nécessiteuses
alors que cette approche qui va
soumettre la réponse au bon vouloir des
investisseurs dépend du degré d'artistes
d'attractivité du dispositif proposé
mais passons sur l'opportunité puisque
les jeux sont faits
l'approché décider parlons donc de
l'efficacité
malgré les modifications du texte actuel
ans semble avoir oublié que trois
évolutions majeures sans retenue à
savoir la crise financière le
plafonnement des niches fiscales
la mise en oeuvre de la loi scellier a
souligné enfin l'impact médiatique de la
situation sociale dans les antilles
françaises qui provoque un désengagement
massif des investisseurs et des concours
bancaires
dans ce climat économique et social un
certain aux données aléatoires
peut-on imaginer aujourd'hui que les
contribuables va prendre le risque
d'investir sur un produit peu rentable
dans un département d'outre-mer
l'architecturé d'une politique de
logement dans les dom devraient porter
sur la diversification des produits
offerts aux populations avec les
perspectives suivante maintien et
confortement de la lbu avec une
adaptation des paramètres de financement
assurons l'equilibre des opérations et
une dotation annuelle équivalente à 270
de 270 à 300 millions d'euros
maintien d'une défiscalisation
patrimonial par le logement
intermédiaire ce qui supposerait une
adaptation de la loi scellier donnant un
avantage aux hommes mise en oeuvre d'un
dispositif de défiscalisation en
location-accession enfin maintien d'un
fonds d'aménagement urbain fera fut
permettant d'assurer le financement des
opérations d'aménagement
il convient de prendre en compte les
handicaps de l'outre-mer en général liés
au plan de prévention des risques au
retard en matière de viabilisation
primaire en intégrant ses propositions
dans une programmation annuelle du
logement par département il nous paraît
possible d'assurer une relance du
logement social et intermédiaire
c'est un peu le sens des divers
amendements proposés par mes collègues
et moi même et j'espère que vous y serez
attentif
merci bien odette terrade vous avez la
parole si monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues cet
article 20 est l'un des articles clés du
projet de loi
ils portent en effet sur la question de
la défiscalisation des opérations de
construction de logement avec la mise en
exergue d'une priorité au financement
d'opérations de construction de
logements sociaux
à vrai dire nous approuvons sur le fond
que l'on produise enfin une
réorientation de la dépense fiscale
destinée à l'outre-mer et que cette
réorientation abandonne les virages les
rivages rebattu de la construction de
logements à visées spéculatives pour
ceux de la réalisation de logements
sociaux
rappelons quelques faits les trois
quarts des foyers fiscaux de l'outre-mer
sont non imposables au titre de l'impôt
sur le revenu ce que signifie que dans
l'hypothèse vraisemblable où ils ne sont
pas propriétaires de leur résidence
principale
ils sont parfaitement en droit de
demander un logement social les éléments
vont être encore plus précis par exemple
pour donner un exemple en 1999
les habitants de la 5e circonscription
législative de la réunion
qui couvre les cantons de bras par ans
de sainte-marie sainte-suzanne
saint-andré saint-benoît la plaine des
palmistes des saladiers étaient logés
dans des logements dépourvus d'eau
chaude pour 40% des familles et l'on
comptait encore plus de 2000 logements
sans sanitaires intérieur dans la
seconde circonscription de guyane qui
couvrent l'essentiel de ce grand
département sauf l'agglomération de
cayenne on comptait moins de 45 % de
logements pourvu d'eau chaude et plus de
20% de logement dépourvu de points d'eau
on peut penser dans les deux cas que la
situation s'est quelque peu améliorée
depuis
mais nous n'en sommes pas tout à fait
certain dans tous les cas puisqu'ils
sont notamment que les articles relatifs
à la zone des 50 pas montre que tout est
loin d'être réglé
toujours est il que la priorité au
logement social et était une évidence
il faut en effet dans les départements
d'outre-mer construire beaucoup de
logements sociaux en s'appuyant sur des
réserves foncières faibles et assez peu
extensible sauf peut-être en guyane et
donc s'appuyer sur ses réserves mais en
ayant le souci de résoudre les problèmes
éventuels de suroccupation de confort
des logements comme de résorption des
habitats insalubres
en procédant à la disparition
progressive de l'habitat de fortune ou
construits illégalement et pour finir en
respectant les normes de construction
antisismiques et anticycloniques
le tout évidemment se fait dans le cadre
de financement tendues
adossé à une ligne budgétaire unique
particulièrement réduite et en
sollicitant des organismes hlm et des
collectivités locales disposant de
moyens somme toute plutôt réduit au
regard de l'immensité de la tâche le
portage les opérations de réalisation de
logements sociaux tel qu'il est prévu
par cet article 20 montre une partie des
problèmes auxquels nous sommes
confrontés
le dispositif de défiscalisation a
manifestement conduit au renchérissement
du foncier
ce qui a contraint les collectivités
locales et les organismes hlm a mobilisé
d'autant plus de moyens pour pouvoir
piloter quelques opérations que l'on
change quelque peu le fusil d'épaulé et
finalement plutôt bienvenu mais appelle
néanmoins quelques observations de plus
et hussein la priorité affiche
à la construction de logements pour en
profiter pour réaliser quelques menues
économies comptables n'est pas plus
admissible car dans l'urgence de la
situation il ne faut pas hésiter à
mobiliser les moyens nécessaires à la
résolution des problèmes
il importe à notre sens de savoir très
vite si d'autres mesures peuvent être
menées pour faciliter la réalisation des
programmes locatifs sociaux qu'attendent
à juste titre les mal logés de
l'outre-mer français
n'y at il pas moyen notamment pour ce
qui est de l'utilisation du domaine
public
malgré les imperfections du cadastre
dont nous avons parlé juste avant le la
coupure du déjeuner de concevoir des
opérations de cessions de terrains
disponibles à titre gratuit ou avec une
importante mine oration prise en charge
en sus de la ligne budgétaire unique
permettant de réaliser dans de
meilleures conditions encore des
opérations de construction
une telle démarche pouvant de fait
s'avérer plus pertinente
on joue sur le prix principal et non pas
seulement sur les coûts fiscaux
accessoires dont plus pertinente qu'une
simple exonération de droits de mutation
en tout cas la situation de l'outre-mer
en matière de logement doit appeler à
l'innovation à la recherche du moindre
coût pour le meilleur service rendu et
au nécessaire effort de solidarité que
nous devons aux populations aujourd'hui
victimes du mal-logement
ce sont là monsieur le président
quelques points que nous notre groupe
souhaitait porter à la connaissance
avant l'examen de cet article si chers
collègues et pour terminer cette série
de demandes d'interventions sur article
la parole est à gélita hoarau
mais résidant sur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues nous
abordons c'est un sujet qui appelle le
plus débat vous connaissez le problème
du logement dans les dom
ils se résument en trois phases phrase
nous avons un besoin cruel de logements
mais la production actuelle ne donne pas
une réponse satisfaisante
plus des deux tiers de nos populations
sont éligibles à un logement social
c'est dans ce contexte que vous décidez
de remettre fondamentalement en cause ce
qui avait été acquis par la loi avec la
loi girardin et qui devait se poursuivre
jusqu'en 2018 vous réformer complètement
les dispositifs de défiscalisation pour
l'accession libre la propriété ainsi que
pour la construction de logements
intermédiaires et vous mettez en place
une défiscalisation pour le logement
social
vous voulez en faire un mécanisme
expérimental qui pourrait être étendue
en métropole par ailleurs le vote dans
la loi de finances 2009 de dispositions
concernant la défiscalisation les
fameuses niches fiscales viennent
compliquer les choses tandis que le
nouveau contexte de crise économique et
financière accentue les difficultés si
le btp devait s'effondrer les
conséquences sociales seront
catastrophiques
entre temps est aussi intervenu le vote
de la loi grenelle 1 qui impose de
nouvelles normes dans la construction de
logements nomme que nous estimons
nécessaire mais qui entraîne de
nouvelles contraintes dans ce contexte
les interrogations quant à l'efficacité
des nouveaux dispositifs proposés se
sont multipliés nous aurons l'occasion
de les signaler dans le débat il y a
donc une unanimité pour dire qu'il faut
revoir quelque peu le dispositif
concernant le logement libre pour le
rendre plus attractif qu'il convient de
donner que de redonner au logement
intermédiaire et intermédiaires social
sa véritable place c'est-à-dire celui de
relais entre le logement social et le
logement libre d'assurer une production
de base du logement social par une
programmation pluriannuelle
et on sent que tu as he is an la lb les
amendements déposés vont dans ce sens
mais je regrette que la question du
logement soit essentiellement traité
dans le projet de loi sous l'angle quasi
unique de son financement
même si c'est un aspect essentiel la
construction d'un logement
c'est bien entendu d'abord répondre à un
besoin social et par conséquence assurer
une bonne cohésion sociale mais c'est
aussi contribuer à la les six mois
terminés aussi le président vous allez
prendre la parole
oui exactement
mais c'est aussi contribuer à la
création sinon au maintien de l'emploi à
la réunion on a coutume de dire que la
construction d'un logement correspond à
un emploi et demi c'est participer à
l'aménagement du territoire et c'est un
élément clé dans le processus du
développement durable aussi pouvons-nous
regretté que certains problèmes se sont
ne sont pas abordés sinon de manière
sommaire au départ il était prévu que le
projet de loi proposera une incitation
aux collectivités pour qu'elles
développent une offre foncière
suffisante
il n'en est plus question dans le texte
discuté aujourd'hui signalent aux
quelques aspects non on peut aborder la
réhabilitation et les moyens de la
réhabilitation le logement des
agriculteurs l'autoconstruction la
construction de logements sociaux et
l'économie alternative pour
l'accompagnement autour du logement
social les questions de l'aménagement le
financement de l'aménagement la
densification la centralité et ses
terrains de même il n'est pas signalé
les nouvelles contraintes
environnementales qui pose les problèmes
de l'aménagement paysager et
architectural pour faire face aux effets
du changement climatique de l'équipement
des logements individuels ou collectifs
en appareils qui économisent l'énergie
de logements écologiques et
ou à haute qualité environnementale
adaptés aux conditions de la réunion est
posée et donc de la recherche de
nouveaux matériaux etc
le fait de ne pas avoir abordé les
questions sociales dans le projet de loi
a eu un effet boomerang
ces problèmes sont revenus dans le débat
par le biais de manifestations et de
grèves prolongées
il nous faut en tirer les leçons en 2004
l'ensemble des acteurs à la réunion y
compris donc l'état et son représentant
avait rédigé un livre blanc sur le
logement social le gouvernement de
l'époque s'était engagé à examiner de
plus près les recommandations présentées
il ne l'a pas fait le 28 février 2007 le
ministre de l'outre-mer organisait je
cite la conférence nationale sur le
logement social outre-mer
le principe de sa transformation en une
instance pérenne d'évaluation de la
politique de l'état et de l'utilisation
des crédits étaient adaptés l'idée
mérite mérite d'être approfondie or
actuellement sous l'impulsion du conseil
général de la réunion des ateliers
travaillent à un plan marshall du
logement social
de nombreux aspects du problème sont
abordés les conclusions qu'il tire on ne
devrait pas rester lettre morte
merci see gélita hoarau se milices vous
avez souhaité réagir réagir ou y
répondre puisque le gouvernement est
interpellé dans ce que j'ai entendu j'ai
entendu beaucoup de choses justes que le
gouvernement partage
et puis alors pardon de le dire mais
beaucoup de caricatures et de gras rica
tueur quelquefois grossière sur cette
question du logement s'accrocher aux
dispositifs de défiscalisation du
logement libre
de d'une manière aussi vigoureuse pour
démontrer que la loi que nous faisons
évoluer était une loi qu'il n'avait
produit que des effets bénéfiques ne
correspond pas à la réalité puisque dans
le même discours vous nous expliquer
qu'il ya une panne terrible sur le
logement social et regardons les
chiffres il y a dans les départements
d'outre-mer plus de cent mille demandes
de logements sociaux non pourvus
est ce qu'on peut se contenter de dire
que les dispositifs que nous avons mises
en place jusqu'à présent sont suffisants
à l'évidence non alors vous avez raison
il faut attraper ce problème par tous
les côtés d'abord mobilisant le foncier
et l'état est prêt à faire des efforts
sur son propre patrimoine pour que l'on
puisse construire du logement social il
appelle aussi les communes les régions
dans le cadre des schémas d'aménagement
régionaux et bien de dégager du foncier
pour construire du logement parce qu'on
peut inventer ici les plus beaux outils
on peut mettre en place et financement
les plus importants si on ne dégage pas
de foncier le logement ne sortira pas de
terre par hasard donc il y à une
mobilisation globale et à travers les
outils que nous vous proposons dans ce
texte il ya évidemment des réponses très
fortes du gouvernement sur ce sujet il
faut évidemment que les critères et les
paramètres de financement du logement
social soit non seulement garantie mais
qu'elle corresponde à la réalité vous ne
pouvez pas ignorer que le 31 janvier
dernier un décret a permis de réviser
les paramètres et qu'aujourd'hui les
professionnels du logement social
considère que les paramètres fixés dans
ce décret permettent de construire des
logements dans de bonnes conditions nous
avons rattrapé le retard sur ce sujet
vous avez raison d'insister sur la ligne
budgétaire unique combien de fois de
vrais jeux répété qu'elle n'est non
seulement pas menacée qu'elle est
pérennisée qu'elle est inscrite dans le
budget qui a été voté par le parlement
pour trois années et que nous sommes pas
790 millions d'euros à 254 millions
d'euros alors j'ai bien entendu certains
souhaitaient que nous allions jusqu'à
270 millions d'euros pourquoi pas si
nous arrivons à la consommer parce que
le paradoxe et mesdames et messieurs que
dans un certain nombre de départements
nous n'arrivions pas à consommer la
ligne
jetair unique tout simplement parce que
les projets n'étaient pas là qu'il
n'était pas sur la table et que nous ne
pouvions pas trouver je pense notamment
et c'est en rien une accusation auprès
du conseil général qui sur cette affaire
mais je pense à la martinique où il ya
une panne dans la construction du
logement social que nous avons déjà
évoqué qui nécessite qu'on puisse se
mobiliser collectivement sur ce sujet et
puis enfin je dirais que presque
philosophiquement je suis très surpris
d'entendre du côté de la gauche de cette
assemblée que mettre la défiscalisation
logement au service du logement social
semble vous choquer faire payer le
logement des plus modestes par les plus
riches me semble être au contraire une
mesure formidable de justice et d'équité
sociale et que le gouvernement justement
mobilisent les fonds là où ils sont pour
ce faire en vous proposons c'est l'objet
de du texte et de l'article que nous
nous allons examiner d'être très souple
lb lui tout seul pas de problème lbe
cumuler avec défiscalisation pas de
problème défiscalisation tout seul pas
de problème non plus c'est la volonté
d'être souple c'est la volonté aussi de
ne pas oublier le logement intermédiaire
effectivement vous avez raison
d'insister sur ce sujet mais de faire en
sorte que celui qui par exemple
construisent un programme de logements
intermédiaires et l'obligation de faire
30 % de logements sociaux comme ça on
aura au moins sûr que les choses
pourront se mettre en oeuvre et puis
enfin c'est tirer les conclusions de la
loi girardin qui a plutôt porté ses
fruits qui a permis de reconstituer le
parc du logement libre mais qui a aussi
connu des dérives à la réunion madame le
sénateur vous le savez bien 100 %
d'augmentation du foncier c'est une des
conséquences malheureuses de cette loi
il fallait donc réorganiser réorienter
le faire de la manière la plus souple
possible en mobilisant le plus de moyens
possibles et en faisant en sorte que
nous soyons le plus créatif possible
c'est je n'en doute pas ce que nous
allons trouver dans les mêmes
amendements que nous allons examiner
maintenant c'est un sujet majeur pour
l'outre-mer c'est une réponse sociale
que celle de mettre le paquet sur le
logement social
et c'est évidemment un des deux piliers
de cette loi que nous vous proposons
d'examiner
maintenant alors nous allons commencer
l'examen des amendements fort nombreux
qui correspondent bien à l'importance de
cet article et c'est michel magras qui
nous présente d'amendements numéro sans
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
l'amendement que je présente vise à
exclure expressément saint-barthélemy du
champ de la défiscalisation du logement
social
je sais que cet argument là cet
amendement la peut surprendre d'autant
plus que j'entends un peu partout les
clichés qui veulent casser martèle me on
ne veut pas de logement social
j'aimerais faire tomber ce cliché là en
vous donnant un certain nombre
d'arguments
le premier argument c'est que mon
amendement n'est pas contre le logement
social c'est un argument contre la
défiscalisation dans le logement ce qui
n'est apte qu'ils soient sociales ou pas
c'est un autre argument le deuxième
c'est que je pense connaître mieux que
quiconque les conditions dans lesquelles
le logement se fait à saint barthélemy
les dispositions prévues dans la loi qui
nous est proposé ne permettront pas de
défiscaliser à saint barthélemy
les taux ne correspondent pas à la
réalité du coût de la vie
al'inverse il se pourrait bien que
certaines entreprises plus ou moins dix
on voudrait nous on voudrait tenter de
nous imposer un logement qui ne
répondent plus aux normes d'urbanisme
d'architecturé ou de sécurité telles
qu'elles sont définies dans notre
collectivité
le troisième argument c'est que le
logement locatif privé à saint
barthélemy est un véritable une
véritable partie de l'économie locale
c'est à dire qu'un grand nombre de
personnes qui sont des salariés et qui
touche à peine le smic grâce à la vente
de parcelles de terrain ont compris
depuis une vingtaine d'années qu'il
valait mieux investis à l'argent de la
vente d'une parcelle de terrain dans la
construction de logements qui sont un
revenu secondaire est la conséquence est
que toutes ces personnes qui aujourd'hui
touchent un smic
vous ne les entendrez jamais se plaindre
de la vie chère et ils ne seront pas
davantage des assistés sociaux parce
qu'ils ont un revenu parallèle le bien
entendu nous sommes particulièrement
conscient des dérives qui s'engage
aujourd'hui
en effet la demande étant supérieure à
l'offre
forcément les prix des loyers se sont
envolés et la collectivité entend bien
essayé de maîtriser les loyers tels
qu'ils sont appliqués sur le territoire
la collectivité j'ai un quatrième
argument cet argument c'est le fait que
nous sommes une île et dans cette île il
ya des traditions et l'une d'entre elles
qui étaient farouchement à laquelle nous
étions tous farouchement accroché c'est
que un jeune avant de fonder son foyer
se devait de construire sa maison
au début c'était avec l'aide des parents
des amis de la famille aujourd'hui c'est
grâce de nouveau à la vente d'une
parcelle de terrain
mais cette tradition se perpétue et de
très nombreux jeunes et y compris ceux
qui viennent de l'extérieur ont compris
l'importance fondamentale qui lie à
accéder le plus vite possible à la
propriété avoir sa propre maison
là aussi bien entendu la collectivité
s'est rendu compte qu'il ne sera pas
possible de permettre à tout le monde
que tout le monde n'aura pas les moyens
c'est pour cette raison que nous avons
mis en place un droit de préemption que
la collectivité applique pour acheter du
terrain qu'elle met à disposition des
jeunes pour la construction de logements
ou qu'elles échangent avec ces jeunes
qui ont des terrains dans les zones
inconstructibles
en fait j'ai un dernier argument il est
de poids nous avons tous entendu
monsieur le ministre ce matin répondant
au rapporteur de la commission des
finances nous dire qu'à saint barthélémy
la collectivité avait la compétence sur
le logement et que de ce fait là nous
n'étions pas concernés par les alizés
les amendements que nous avons voté ce
matin ça a été confirmée lorsque j'ai
moi-même sous-amendé l'amendement du
sénateur virapoullé
je rappelle qu'en plus d'avoir la
compétence en matière de logement nous
avons la compétence en matière
d'urbanisme et mieux encore nous avons
la compétence en matière fiscale
il serait donc malvenu de voir le
législateur nous imposer de la
défiscalisation dans des domaines de
compétence qui relève exclusivement de
la collectivité donc mes chers collègues
j'ai tenu à dresser cet argumentaire
pour que chacun comprenne que je sais
que c'est encore une position singulière
par rapport à l'outre-mer je sais aussi
que je soutiens la position de
l'outre-mer sur la démarche que j'ai
entendue depuis tout à l'heure mais
j'aimerais que vous compreniez la mienne
et que vous acceptiez de voter
l'amendement que je vous propose ici
alors monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président merci de me donner la parole
merci à monsieur magra d'avoir donné
tous les éléments pour appuyer son
amendement le principe de la commission
des finances est d'ailleurs pense que
nous déposerons tout à l'heure un
amendement dans ce sens et que si une
collectivité ne veut pas maintenir un
dispositif de fiscalisation et bien
qu'elle ait la possibilité de voter à un
moment donné la non application de ce
dispositif dans sa collectivité donc on
en reparlera tout à l'heure pour ces
raisons nous sommes favorable à
l'amendement qui a été déposé ce
ministre
le gouvernement est tiraillé entre
l'avis de la commission qui l'écoutent
avec beaucoup de respect d'attention
depuis le début de ses travaux
les arguments qui sont les vôtres
monsieur le sénateur en disant nous ne
sommes pas contre le logement social ne
refusons pas l'idée qu'il y ait du
logement social
nous refusons l'idée de la
défiscalisation
j'aimerais c'est une position que le
gouvernement est particulier le
ministère des finances ne pourrait qu
approuvé avec beaucoup de vigueur je
suis aussi interpellé par la capacité
que vous avez eu de reprendre mes propos
vous avez de bonnes situations où
effectivement vous avez la loi vous
adonner en temps de collectivités la
compétence fiscale la compétence
d'urbanisme et la compétence de
logements vouloir vous imposer un
dispositif alors qu'on vous a donné les
compétences ça semble aussi antinomie
car je suis aussi tiraillé par le fait
de dire que la vie d'une collectivité ou
de ses élus est important que l'intérêt
général peut être commandée aussi de
regarder si ça ne peut pas avoir des
effets pervers
et si l'intérêt des habitants ne doit
pas être prise en compte
dernier point de l'interrogation du
gouvernement c'est l'annoncent par
monsieur le rapporteur d'un amendement
qui serait un amendement général chapeau
si j'ose dire qui pourrait peut-être
permettre aux collectivités d'avoir une
sorte de droit d'option sur les mesures
qui sont proposés pour celles qui
voudraient ou qui ne voudrait pas face à
tout ça je m'en remets à la sagesse de
la haute assemblée alors nous avons un
avis favorable et sagesse jean claude
frécon vous avez la parole
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues j'ai écouté avec
attention beaucoup d'attention les
propos de notre collègue monsieur mac
race car j'étais surpris par le texte de
cet amendement et je voudrais vous faire
part très rapidement de cette petite
surprise
nous sommes dans la république française
tous notre république par
l'intermédiaire des déclarations de ses
plus hauts dirigeants a dit ces derniers
temps que la mixité sociale était aussi
un des éléments d'une gage d'une dent
gage d'une bonne fraternité entre les
différentes parties entre les différents
corps sociaux qui vivent dans un
territoire limité alors vous avez bien
pris la présidence la précaution de dire
que vous n'étiez par contre le logement
social mais contre la défiscalisation
y at il beaucoup de logement social à
saint barthélemy vous le savez mon cher
collègue muc moi vous n'avez pas dix
mille habitants donc vous n'êtes pas
soumis à la loi sru
mais quel que soit ce pourcentage de
logement social que vous avez je doute
d'après la rédaction de votre amendement
que vous dites que le logement social
locatif libre est considéré à
saint-barthélemy comme un secteur
économique à part entière et qu'il n'y a
pas besoin de l'autre
donc je pense qu'il doit pas y avoir
beaucoup de logement social eh bien je
lui dis qu'au nom du principe de la
république une et indivisible sur la
mixité sociale
cela m'embête cela me surprendrait me
choquerait que le territoire de saint
barthélemy ne soit pas comme les autres
territoires de la république française
deuxièmement on nous et nous arrive
l'information que un amendement on
pourrait effectivement proposé que des
collectivités
puis se distraire une défiscalisation
qui ne la concerne pas je trouve que
dans ce cas là ce sera effectivement une
bonne solution et qui permettrait de
résoudre éventuellement votre problème
mais si on lit bien aussi le premier
arctique
la première le premier alinéa de
l'article 20 qu'est ce qu'on dit on dit
que pour les investissements réalisés à
compter du 1er janvier 2010 dans un
certain nombre de territoires dont saint
barthélémy le présent article ne
s'applique que si une convention fiscale
contenant une clause d'assistance
administrative en vue de lutter contre
la fraude ou l'évasion fiscale a été
conclu entre la collectivité concernée
l'état cela veut dire que si vous ne
voulez pas signer cette convention
cet article ne s'applique pas la
solution est donc dans vos mains mais le
texte à mon avis de rester un texte
général pour l'ensemble du territoire
français notre fric on y at il d'autres
demandes d'intervention michel magras
pour expliquer cette poule oui juste
pour apporter quand même quelques
informations à la dernière intervention
bon c'est vrai qu'à saint barth et demi
je le reconnais publiquement il n'y a
pas de logement social pourquoi n'y at
il pas le logement social parce que le
besoin ne s'est jamais fait sentir on
peut le prouver quand vous voulez j'ai
expliqué clairement la manière dont les
générations les unes après les autres
accès de logements c'est c'est démontrer
c'est visible n'importe qui peut se
rendre à saint barth et le voir la
deuxième chose c'est que la convention
fiscale
la convention fiscale fait partie des
accords signés moraux que nous avons
passé avec le gouvernement dès le vote
de la loi qui nous concerne et nous
n'arrêtons pas d'interpeller le
gouvernement sur l'urgence qu'il y à a
signé cette convention fiscale
c'est exactement donc le contraire nous
voulons la signer elle est m'a-t-on dit
et interrogé officiellement la semaine
dernière le ministère concerné pour être
certains de mes interventions en
particulier sur l'article 1er et si je
ne suis pas intervenu c'est parce que
j'ai obtenu les assurances qui me
permettait de comprendre que nous étions
exclus de mais je veux pas refaire ce
débat aujourd'hui
donc j'estime honnêtement que le
développement de saint barth ennemis tel
qu'il a été conduit
moi j'invite celui qui veut à venir se
rendre compte et ça il s'apercevra que
les choix qui ont été faits sont ceux
qui correspondent aux besoins de la
population et que la population on est
particulièrement satisfaite sur le
président vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président l'amendement dans
son collègue madre à la droite au coeur
de la commission des finances dans la
mesure où il restreint le champ de la
défiscalisation
donc il est à priori à nos yeux un bon
amendement en ce qu'il ne détériore pas
le solde des finances publiques
maintenant nous avons eu déjà un débat
sur sur ce sujet et nous allons vous
proposer un amendement à l'article 20
terre et qui à mon avis doit répondre à
votre souhait c'est à dire que la loi
définit un champ relativement large de
défiscalisation possible et puis si cet
amendement est voté il confère aux
assemblées territoriales ultramarines
le pouvoir de délibérer sur une
réduction de ce chant et ceux ci
seraient accessibles aux autorités
territoriales dans les six mois qui
suivraient la promulgation de la loi
dont nous discutons le contenu et puis
il serait dit que au lendemain de chaque
renouvellement de l'assemblée
territoriale pendant un délai de six
mois
il serait possible de délibérer sur la
lame la révocation de ce qui a été
décidé précédemment ou bien
l'élargissement de ce qui ne serait plus
défiscalisables donc il me semble que
vous pourriez peut-être retirer votre
amendement sans préjuger du vote qui
interviendra sur l'amendement va vous
proposer la commission des finances
fourcade et puis michel magras merci
monsieur le président oui moi je trouve
que l'amendement de monsieur madras un
très gros avantage il montre le lien qui
existe entre la défiscalisation et
l'augmentation des prix du foncier et je
crois que c'est parce qu'on a un peu
trop abusé des mécanismes de
défiscalisation
quand la fabriquer quand la facilité des
augmentations de prix qui évidemment
repose ensuite sur l'ensemble de la
population alors je n'ai pas encore vu
l'amendement dont on vient de parler
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui sauf si le retire mes
collègues du groupe ump voteront
l'amendement de monsieur bagarre magra
alors michel magras qu'est ce que l'on
fait monsieur le président je suis bien
embarrassée parce que j'ai entendu à la
j'ai entendu l'avis du président de la
commission des finances
il sait déjà le respect que je lui porte
et puis la clarté de son exposé
j'ai eu à connaître le contenu de cet
amendement est en entrant tout à l'heure
dans cette salle je me disais que dès
lors que l'amendement 20h à l'article 21
que nous déposons est satisfait la
collectivité aurait la garantie que
c'est elle qui décide
puisque
elle serait non seulement consulter mais
son avis serait prépondérant dans les
décisions en matière de défiscalisation
je suis hésitant parce qu'en même temps
ça me ferait plaisir de satisfaire la
l'intervention qui a été fait par le
collègue de deux socialistes
et puis donc tout compte fait plutôt que
de semer un peu le doute dans l'esprit
de chacun je crois que je vais retirer
cet amendement
mon numéro s'en est retirée nous
examinons six amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune et
c'est notre collègue louis constant
fleming qui a la parole il est retiré
le 5 est retiré anne marie payet le 291
rectifier et retirer le 99 et il est
retiré
oui il s'agissait d'un abonnement de
conséquence du premier amendement
il est retiré j'avais cru analysé le 99
et retirer le 227
alors c'est gaston flosse qui nous le
présente vous avez la parole monsieur le
sénateur président comme l'indiquent le
conseil économique social et
environnemental dans l'aviron du ch le
projet de loi la disposition doit rester
en rapport avec l'objectif du projet il
ya donc lieu de préciser que la
convention pour le but de favoriser la
lutte contre les détournements dont
pourrait être l'objet les avantages
fiscaux consentis aux titres de
l'aide à l'investissement outre-mer
alors quel est l'avis de la commission
l'avis de la commission
compte tenu de la nature de l'amendement
qui vise que le contrôle que le contrôle
des fonds défiscaliser ne peut pas être
être suivi donc l'amendement qu'il est
posée par notre collègue puisque
l'objectif de lutte contre la fraude
fiscale justifie que les conventions
précisent et globale soit passé entre
l'état les collectivités d'outre-mer qui
dispose d'une autonomie fiscale donc on
ne peut pas limiter donc on est
défavorable ce mini s'il en est de même
deux avis défavorables at il des
demandes d'explications de vote requis
pour adopter cet amendement qui est pour
et qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
c'est notre collègue là où fois où l'eau
qui nous présente de souza et ben le
sous-amendement la maman oui pardon
avril est suivie d'un sous-amendement
alors vous avez la parole le président
compléter l'article 40 alinéa en vue de
lutter contre la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale la collectivité de laisser
futuna transmet à l'état toute
information utile au contrôle de
l'avantagé fiscal accordé
je me permet de lire tout le
l'amendement parce que ça permettra à
quelques refrains aux collègues qui
veulent m'attaquez sur ce qui a été dit
hier le comprendre qu'on est en train de
faire des efforts pour aller contre ce
que
ce qui se passe actuellement sur le
territoire donc 7
cet amendement vise à adapter le
dispositif de contrôle aux
caractéristiques propres des
institutions de la collectivité de
wallis et futuna
merci alors le gouvernement a souhaité
sous-amendé reculant devant aucun
sacrifice gouvernement propose de
sous-amendé comme il l'a fait dès hier
d'ailleurs sur un amendement à peu près
similaire c'est à dire de supprimer la
fin de la phrase en vue de lutter contre
la fraude et l'évasion fiscale la
collectivité de wallis et futuna
transmet à l'état toute information
utile points et de s'en arrêter là
c'est à dire de supprimer au contrôle de
l'avantagé fiscal accordé simplement
vous des raisons juridiques pour éviter
qu'il y ait des contestations sur le
texte
les choses sont claires et on enlève ces
quatre mots et ça alors si c'est pas
tout à fait ce qui est marqué sur le
sous-amendement non le sait le 443 le
sous-amendement 443 rectifier voilà
alors le sous amendement supprime la
femme ma phrase non la fin de la phrase
et il resterait donc une fois ce sous
amendement
à voter dans l'amendement s'il était
voté la phrase suivante en vue de lutter
contre la fraude et l'évasion fiscale la
collectivité de wallis et futuna
transmet à d'état toute information
utile point ça c'est ce qui reste ce que
le gouvernement dans ce sous amendement
souhaitant lever c'est au contrôle de
l'avantagé fiscal accordé
on souhaite que cette partie de phrases
disparaître simplement pour des raisons
de recours et de contentieux possible
voilà est-ce que j'ai été clair voilà
c'était c'est pour ça que je vous disais
c'est le 443 rectifié jean claude frécon
donc monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
sur le sous-amendement et d'amendements
c'est monsieur le président c'est
exactement la même manipulation qui hier
à l'article 7
enfin manipulation je retire le terme
elle a même principe
voilà et donc comme nous y étions
favorables yeah eh bien nous y sommes
favorables aujourd'hui
et voilà donc le gouvernement suit
puisqu'il a sous-amendé y at il des
demandes d'explications de vote qui est
pour adopter le sous-amendement et
l'amendement ainsi sous-amendé ces mêmes
votes
il est adopté je vous remercie
alors je rappelle que pour la clarté nos
débats il a été décidé sur proposition
de la commission des finances de
procéder à l'examen séparer de
l'amendement numéro 127 de suppression
des deuxièmement à cinquièmement du
grand teint de cet article alors le 127
cdc d'autres collègues
serge larcher qui nous présente mais si
monsieur le président fulminent cheyrou
legs convoi lauf obligés de nous
parlementaires d'opposition de nous
battre à bout tenter de sauver quelques
mesures positives des lois pour ramon
votée en juillet 2003
toujours est il que vouloir déployer la
défiscalisation le but logement vers le
logement social on laisse froid du par
hasard 2/3 de la volonté inavouée de
tuer cette défiscalisation coupe mais
défiscalisé logement social en lieu et
place de joueurs libres ou intermédiaire
diminuer l'attrait fortement l'intérêt
de l'investissement pour les
investisseurs métropolitains qui dit
largement social du plafonnement des
loyers de baisse des revenus
une telle orientation gouvernementale
l'outre-mer n'est nullement d'accroître
les avantages fiscaux liés à
l'investissement locatif social
c'est même tout le contraire là sur la
base de ce type de simulation de la
fédération des scènes d'outre-mer
l'hypothèse d'une rentabilité négative
de l'investissement leur aide sociale
outre-mer est de loin la plus probable
elle est propice à décourager les
investisseurs a fortiori dans un
contexte de forte remontée de taux
d'intérêt notamment le secteur ni
oublier le brief annoncé par cette
mesure est de relancer la politique du
logement dans les dom en train est il
réellement
le projet de loi jégo supprima réel à la
croise en réalité la quasi totalité de
la défiscalisation des logements libres
ou intermédiaire dans le cadre actuel
dont la collection est issu de la loi
girardin est réservé le bénéfice de
cette dépense fiscale aux seuls
programmes immobiliers comprenant un
certain pourcentage de logements sociaux
donné en location sous une double
condition de plafond concernant d'une
part le loyer et d'autre part les
ressources des locataires
ce recentrage de l'éducation primaire et
pour a été à une objectif d'un
allègement des contraintes financières
pour l'état
nous savons tous que là c'est la nba qui
finance le logement social est
d'ailleurs resté le soft financement et
l'orestie finances au financement de
social et le dispositif de
défiscalisation pour poser d'un projet
de loi devrait permettre une production
complémentaire de logements sociaux et
intermédiaires et en aucun cas sauf si
tu es se substituer à la ressource
budgétaire
en effet le dispositif de
défiscalisation est une ressource
aléatoire par nature qu'elle dépend de
la dynamique des six des investisseurs
or dans le contexte actuel de crise
sociale dans les débats sont entremêlées
crise financière générale
personne ne peut être assurée du de la
mobilisation de la ressource
à court terme la zone pour laquelle nous
souhaitons introduire le dispositif de
défiscalisation de logements
intermédiaires et de logements libres
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
mais monsieur le président est jamais
très facile de discuter et d'essayer de
faire voter une loi je me souviens des
débats qu'on a eu il ya quelques années
lorsque madame gérardin a présenté son
texte on a eu quelques peu le sentiment
parfois que les dispositions que vous
défendez aujourd'hui vous les avez quand
même un petit peu un petit peu combattu
une seule à l'époque alors il va me
nommer c'est vrai il faut le redire
alors on le redit bon donc il ya eu des
aspects extrêmement positif et on l'a
dit à plusieurs reprises de la loi
girardin elle ministre l'a rappelé tout
à l'heure et il ya eu quelques aspects
qui pose qui pose problème donc nous
pensons que les suppressions que vous
demandez ne sont pas justifiées et c'est
la raison pour laquelle on apportera une
réponse défavorable à votre demande
d'amendement le ministre avoir toujours
raison est un grand tort disait edgar
faure en tout cas il avait titré ses
mémoires de cette manière là peut lui
rendre hommage à cette occasion et
le gouvernement avait raison à
l'occasion de la loi girardin de
proposer la défiscalisation du logement
libre ça a permis de faire décoller le
secteur de soutenir le bâtiment et
travaux publics et de reconstituer le
parc
si vous aviez eu tort à l'époque de vous
y opposer aujourd'hui le gouvernement a
raison de réorienter l'outil fiscal vers
le logement social parce qu'il faut
reconstituer le parc
je ne voudrais pas parce que je sais que
vous êtes tout à fait soucieux de
l'intérêt général je ne voudrais pas que
dans quelques années vous défendiez ici
cet amendement que vous refusez face ce
texte que vous refusez aujourd'hui et je
vous dis que évidemment gouvernement va
donner un avis défavorable
je vais bien entendu le message nous
allons d'ailleurs dans les délais à
porter pour la fin de l'époque de la
défiscalisation du logement libre donner
des délais tout à fait raisonnable pour
permettre au projet de se de prospérer
mais je vous dis sincèrement que ce
serait une erreur majeure que de garder
l'outil tel qu'il est à taux plein parce
qu'il continuerait de faire monter le
foncier qu'il règlerait pas
parallèlement la question du logement
social donc nous nous avons peut-être à
nouveau raison en anticipation mais je
suis sûr que vous viendrez aussi sur ce
dispositif est que le la nostalgie d'un
dispositif que vous avez combattu puis
soutenu passera très vite puisque vous
apercevrez que le dispositif jégo
puisque vous avez vous bien voulu
l'appeler comme ça c'est trop d'honneur
sera aussi efficace que le dispositif
girardin sur un autre domaine qui est
celui du logement social
alors nous avons deux avis défavorables
at il des demandes d'explication de
votre alors notre collègue antoinette
merci j'ai présidence simplement pour
rester
pour répondre à ce qu'a dit donc le
rapporteur et et monsieur le ministre
depuis mardi qui a débuté l'examen de
cette loi
on nous reprochait au départ des trains
peu dogmatique
après on a dit que pourquoi pas ne sont
prêts à parce que nous l'a imposée à
apporter des ajustements pour améliorer
cette loi et quand nos points de vue
pragmatique lui disant qu' il y a eu des
dispositifs qui en fonctionner tel que
le dispositif girardin
on nous reproche maintenant de défendre
une loi à laquelle certains d'entre nous
n'avait pas soutenu
je crois que là on s'écarte un peu du
fond du sujet car maintenant si on fait
de l'analyse
qu'est ce qui bloque la production du
logement en guyane comme aux antilles
il s'agit en particulier du financement
des équipements primaire en le
financement des équipements primaire
n'est pas prévu dans le cadre de la
défiscalisation
c'est pour cette raison que nous
existons lourdement pour dire que un des
moyens pour débloquer le logement social
consiste dans un premier temps à
renforcer la lb eu car seule la elle pu
nous permettra de financer cette
première phase est indispensable à
savoir les investissements primaire
comment mettre à la disposition des
sociétés des sociétés aient un terme et
des sociétés pendant de production de
logements des terrains aménagés et
ensuite parce qu'effectivement par
rapport à toutes les raisons que nous
avons évoquées
pensez vous qu'un investisseur va se
pencher vers le logement social et on
voit bien d'ailleurs que certains
d'entre nous tente de trouver des
dispositifs justement pour de façon
assez subtil échapper à un des grands
principes celui de la mixité sociale
celui de la production du logement qui
est devenu un droit opposable
voilà pourquoi quelques fois nous disons
nous devons nous reposer sur ce soap sur
ce soft qui relève de politiques
publiques à savoir le
l'augmentation est le maintien de la ld
eu par rapport à cet objectif national à
savoir combler le déficit de logements
sociaux soit dette nous avons deux avis
défavorables
claude lise merci monsieur le président
je n'avais pas prévu d'intervenir et
j'avais voulu faire gagner du temps et
ne pas intervenir sur le logement
mais j'avoue que je commence à être un
peu choqué de voir caricaturé les
positions de certains d'entre nous sur
le problème de la défiscalisation d'une
manière générale ce n'est pas possible
de continuer comme cela
moi je suis très à l'aise très cohérent
à l'époque où j'étais membre de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
nationale j'ai été de ceux qui ont
demandé le fameux rapport aux riches à
et donc on a corrigé la loi pousse à
l'époque je crois qu'on a fait de bonnes
choses on assainit surprise n la
commission des finances
et puis au moment de du débat sur la loi
girardin
j'ai proposé j'ai les amendements j'ai
proposé un système de contrôle et un
système de pénalités 1 pour ce qui de ne
crée pas d'emplois ou ne faisait pas de
l'investissement productif
j'ai proposé également quelque chose
qu'on a rejeté à l'époque ici même en me
disant que ce n'était pas possible
mais qui est maintenant devenu possible
c'est à dire demander l'avis des
collectivités locales si si on avait
écouté cette dame si on avait suivi
cette demande
je pense que souvent nos idées avis
pertinent sur les opérations méritant
d'être d'être défiscaliser ou pas donc
vraiment je je tiens à dire que nous
sommes un certain nombre à avoir une
position cohérente la défiscalisation
est un bon instrument mais à condition
qu'on y met des comptoirs nous sommes
pas des fanatiques de la défisc mais
nous sommes d'accord condition qu'il y
ait des contrôles je veux ajouter que
sur sur le problème de la lb eu oui nous
avons besoin de élevés notamment pour la
réhabilitation on va y venir tout à
l'heure la réhabilitation et vous savez
bien qu'il en a manqué à certains
moments ce qu'il ya eu des dettes
contractées à l'égard de l'entreprise
qui s'occupe de réhabilitation d'autre
part dire systématiquement immonde du
foncier
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas suffisant de
foncier même martinique et en guadeloupe
mais il ya aussi le problème comme l'a
dit le collègue à l'instant même de la
viabilisation et joidon conseil général
met beaucoup d'argent sur sur ce plan là
dans le cadre du fra fut il faudrait
peut-être que l'état mette un peu plus
car c'est là un problème vient du
foncier mais pas réhabilités et par
conséquent vous riez il faut quand même
pas là non plus schématiser un peu trop
les choses et claude lise lucette
michaux chevry
je pense que le gouvernement fait un
acte de courage
on a en effet fortement critiqué la loi
gigandet notamment parce
qu'effectivement elle a profité ce
dispositif à favoriser la construction
de logements humaines de ghetto il y a
quand même des zones en guadeloupe à
marie galante où des gens construit
mettre des barrières on peut plus
pénétrer même pas pour aller à la plage
aujourd'hui le gouvernement veut mettre
faire cela et il a raison la mois d'août
c'est en nous ça voulait dire quoi qu'il
y en a assez de voir des gens qui ne
sont pas de la guadeloupe qui viennent
construire du logement et qui le loue
dans des conditions insupportables je
crois que les jeunes générations ont
besoin et c'est une vision courageuse
d'avoir du terrain pour construire leur
maison
mais non en ce qui concerne la lb il est
clair qu'on commence à faire passer dans
l'opinion que y aura plus du sbu
il y aura que de la défiscalisation je
crois que il faut aussi peut-être qu'ici
un langage est dehors il y en a
au langage mais le langage c'est que il
y en avait eu plus il y a de la
défiscalisation maman revendications
c'est de demander au gouvernement ce que
je n'ai toujours dit aux ministres de
veiller à ce que les problèmes
d'assainissement les problèmes en eau
potable qui ne sont pas toujours soutenu
par certaines collectivités locales qui
ont des connotations politicienne de
préférence qu'on puisse régler ses
problèmes d'assainissement et d'eau
potable je sais ce que je dis je préside
une communauté de communes j'ai un
schéma d'aménagement d'eau et
d'assainissement
et si je n'avais pas le soutien que les
cas nous n'aurions pas eu de logement
social chez nous parce que tous les
dossiers de la communauté que je préside
madame sont jetés pour des raisons
politiciennes et je pèse mes mots
politicienne jeune élu pour défendre la
population que le soutien de l'état
alors ne faisons pas ici de grands
discours hypocrite
soyons très clairs le courage est de
notre côté dans un dossier qui intéresse
la population
merci il n'y a plus de demandes de
d'explications de vote
alors qui est pour adopter l'amendement
de serge larcher et pour pied contre il
n'est pas adopté nous passons à l'examen
de quatre amendements qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune
la parole est à claude lise pour nous
présenter le 128 rectifier merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre collègues
on compte environ 70000 logements
insalubres sur l'ensemble des
départements d'outre-mer
c'est mieux qu'en martinique qui sont
occupé en majorité par des personnages
et souvent d'ailleurs personne en
difficulté quelquefois même grande
précarité
et il faut savoir que la plupart de ces
personnes âgées sont propriétaires de la
loge de leur logement
c'est une caractéristique de nos
départements beaucoup de deux personnes
âgées propriétaires de logements mais de
logements qui qui sont des logements un
peu un peu souvent pris en situation
d'insalubrité ou au moins de précarité
ces logements qui sont souvent anciens
subissent précisément des dégradations
importantes dues aux conditions
climatiques et géologiques de nos
régions il faut savoir que les
résidences principales achevé avant 1975
sont sont encore très nombreuses en
martinique c 39 % du parc immobilier
lana intervient dans les dom et
intervient très modestement pour aider
au financement de la réhabilitation de
logements détenus par les propriétaires
d'ailleurs mais pas pour les
propriétaires occupants
l'amendement présenté l'amendement 128
propose de maintenir le dispositif de
défiscalisation au moins pour les
propriétaires bailleurs
je tiens à souligner qu'en favorisant la
réhabilitation au contribue bien entendu
à rendre ces associations contribuent
aussi à dynamiser un secteur d'activité
qui compte essentiellement des petites
entreprises petites entreprises qui sont
d'ailleurs pourvoyeuse d'emplois en
grande quantité c'est plus de 2400
personnes qui travaillent dans ce
secteur en martinique
donc je pense qu'il est extrêmement
important de
faire en sorte que ces propriétaires
occupants soit aidé ce dispositif là a
donné de bons résultats
je pense qu'il faut aller encore plus
loin dans ce domaine là d'ailleurs c'est
le seul secteur capable de produire dans
des délais très courts une réponse
adaptée à la forte demande non seulement
de logements sociaux mais mais même de
logements intermédiaires
daniel marsin vous partager ce point de
vue et monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je crois
que tout le débat qu'on a eu en début
d'après-midi montre bien commun est
important la question du logement et
combien effectivement dans la loi
girardin
il y avait du bon puis du bon qui était
peut-être bon à un moment moins bon
aujourd'hui a du bon qui demeure et
parmi ce bon je crois que la lan
girondins avaient institué un dispositif
de réduction d'impôt au titre des
travaux de réhabilitation réalisés par
une entreprise pour des logements
anciens de plus de 40 ans ce dispositif
a été supprimée par l'article 20 du
présent projet de loi en cette
disposition et je crois que le collègue
lise le disais tout à l'heure pour une
certaine catégorie de logements sa
disposition ça justifie par la situation
particulièrement dégradée du logement à
notre mère et parmi les chiffres on peut
citer on peut citer 25% de logements
précaires ou dépourvues d'éléments de
confort ou près de 15% de logements
insalubres
elle se justifie également par les aléas
climatiques spécifiques à l'outre-mer
qui conduisent à une déclaration plus
rapide des logements c'est pourquoi cet
amendement que je présente au nom de la
commission des affaires économiques
visent non seulement maintenir le
dispositif de la loi girardin doc à le
réintroduire mais également à l'élargir
au logement de plus de 20 ans pour tenir
compte justement de la vitesse de
dégradation plus rapide des logements à
notre merde sur le ministre
alors la différence c'est surtout la
levée du gaj vous avez la parole oui moi
je voudrais attirer l'attention de
l'assemblée sur la qualité de notre
travail depuis deux jours sur je crois à
l'esprit qui règne sur le fait que quand
le gouvernement une appréciations
divergentes sur une orientation le 10
mai quand le gouvernement est d'accord
avec les propositions des parlementaires
et il n'hésite pas à le dire je vais
donc retiré l'amendement du gouvernement
au profit de la commandement défendu par
claude lise et remercier claude lise et
les élus daniel marsin anne marie payet
tous les élus signataires qui ont déposé
cet amendement d'abord pouvoir attirer
l'attention du gouvernement sur ce cette
demande sur ce besoin pour avoir accepté
de passer à 20 ans la période parce que
il s'avérait que dans la loi girardin
les 40 ans était un facteur bloquant sur
ce sujet et pour vous montrer qu'on peut
faire de la coproduction intelligente et
que dans ce projet de loi il ya matière
à ce que chacun y retrouve ses intérêts
privilégié et ses priorités le
gouvernement retire son amendement et
apportera son plein soutien à
l'amendement
lise mars un payet c'est un hommage à la
coproduction et aux sénateurs concernés
bon à tous les ultramarins qui ont fait
1 alors le sens qu 416 du gouvernement
est retirée alors ils sont rendu
identique
anne marie payet il est défendu le gage
élevé bien entendu et monsieur le
rapporteur
que vous reste-t-il à dire bien d'abord
je voudrais dire amicalement à notre
collègue claude lise que tout à l'heure
j'ai vu qu'il était quelque peu agacé
par les propos que j'ai tenus mais je
lui ferai remarquer également qu'il m'a
dit en réponse qu'il avait eu raison à
l'époque et que nous avions pas une je
dirais
ne l'avions pas écouter et à tort je
reconnais qu'à l'époque nous avions eu
tort de ne pas vous écoutez que vous
aviez raison donc je crois qu'il faut
savoir reconnaître ses positions 1
voilà bon alors effectivement il me
paraît difficile de dire qu'on est pas
favorable
on est effectivement tout à fait
favorable et on n'a pas attendu
d'ailleurs d'avoir les autres
amendements pour donner un avis
favorable à celui déposé par claude lise
et ses collègues donc on l'a prouvé bien
évidemment tous ceux qui étaient dans
les quatre amendements dans les quatre
amendements merci y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote
non alors je considère que les trois
amendements restant en débats sont
adoptés à l'unanimité
ils sont adoptés à l'unanimité
le 128 rectifié 381 elle 350 de
rectifier bis
vous venez de suivre la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi relatif au
développement économique de l'outre-mer
les sénateurs devraient terminer
l'examen de ce projet de loi de ce soir
merci votre attention et à très bientôt
sur public sénat